Oh, I
Don't know what we're watching here
I'm not 100% sure. I just loaded up the game and apparently there's an epilepsy warning. So be careful about that
lots of flashing colors
"Help"
Okay..
I'm always down to help..
Theeere you go-
Bonjour!
Bonjoure!
Oh..
(odd, surreal music)
HuUh....
Right, hello everybody welcome to Puss! I think I'm supposed to click-and-drag..
Yeah, okay everybody this is um..
..this is a game that I don't think I'm..
..going to be able to explain
So this is uh
This is puss puss is do you remember that?
Do you remember that a maze game from a long time ago?
That was a prank that when you got close to the end. It just ended up jump scaring you
Well, that's like that game expanded into a full game as far as I know
Okay world complete
We are going to show you we're gonna show me what you're gonna show me a good time
You're gonna show me how to learn to hate myself
As many things that games tried to teach me throughout this experience, oh I
Got some things I guess I get some more lives from when I eventually screw this all up. I don't like that
This is going towards a pentagram and also oh, oh no, it's like a mixture of the world's hardest game. Oh, I'm
Sorry, I'm sorry
Oh
My corpse all my corpulent corpse. Oh my splatter corpse. Oh goodness gravy. Can I collect any of that?
Nope, that's just that's his gun
He's a straight-up corpsey corpse. Okay, Wow, okay
Did it?
Something beautiful we're gonna show me something beautiful. Is that what you're gonna show me I don't believe it but oh
Ye, I'm sorry. I
Hi
Duchamp
Okay Duchamp, I don't know if there was something that was supposed to be there
is there a reason that there were two of those or is it just
Hi, oh
Yeah, that's
Okay, all right, well I don't like the way those cats are staring at me but yeah
Yeah
Yay
Where is this going it? Where are you taking me? Oh, I don't know. I think I did that. Okay
Oh
I know I need to go around of course. It makes so much sense now
I don't like the cries of the cats in the back. I
Don't like anything about this. I got so many questions about what the hell has happened. Is that potatoes?
Why is it raining potatoes on Mother Mary?
Shit that was right off the bat no stupid of me right off the bad boy bad boy. Okay. Here we go
Here we go. Here we go. Oh, no here. We don't go. We're not going all we're going we're going
Okay, so I just got to find the safety zones. And once I find the safety zones, I am good to go. Oh
It's a checkpoint
Oh
Yeah, good thing. I got such great hand-eye coordination. This is great. Everything's fine. Everything's fine about this. This is great
Oh my god. Oh
I don't like you moving like that. Oh, yeah. Hey, oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Sorry
No, oh this ins this one's gonna be a little tough oh
I just have so why closes the closes this is closes like a shop it closes
Why have you closed your doors to the ball?
Frick god damn it. I'm gonna run lives Oh
Tits I'm gonna run out of lives. Just gotta be patient. The name of the game is
Patience. Okay. Wait, here we go. Here's my chance. Oh, no. Oh my god Go Go. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god
Oh
Well, that was more stressful than I ever wanted, okay, but good. I'm alive ins that I can keep going
Okay, I'm almost to the pentagram that's got to be good one eye here
Frogger we playing Frogger here. Is that what we's do?
Blink, it's locked the button in Mario. Once you press it some happens not sure do I need to go back
Do I need to go?
I am fine. I am fine. I am fine taking the second bus. I am fine
Got it nailing this super hard. That's too fast
Thank you for the bigger boat. Uh
I
I Made it Hey visit the steam group. I don't like that. That kid doesn't have a lower half. That's not good. All right Bo
Her we go to the pentagram!
Whoo
What is happening I am so with me questions
Hello, why does it keep getting more insane every time I turn a corner every new level is just a new level of a sanity
What is happening? What's happening - plus I guess I'll stop okay
Thank you, you are so kind
No hard pass this is that peer pressure I was warned about these are the drugs
How's it now, I don't like the sound of sacrifice that sounds like it might be me
Don't bless us bless you did you sneeze. Oh you were the sacrifice? Oh
Oh, I can't move there we go. Oh, whoa wait stop. How can I'm not
I don't get it. Okay, that was unfortunate. I was trying to not die and then I'm dying. Okay, I'm good at bullet
Hell's I know I'm good at these. Okay. All right. All right. Just gotta do I don't like that too where oh wow
Stop it you Oh. Oh, that's not good. Oh, oh shit. Sneeze. Sneeze. Oh, there we go pow
Okay, one more one more one more and I'm out. I'm out, baby
Okay, pal. Oh
Shit
Guy you scratched up to hell him back. Yeah. Yeah, you don't yeah. Yeah, it wasn't one half your health
Yeah, what are you gonna do about nothing? Oh, okay
All that I don't like to look at that
Oh my god, Cerberus Oh who's a big boy?
Who's who's uh, shit Oh, who's uh, who's our bigger?
Rick oh god. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god, ah shit
Oh you have so many eyes stop. Look I'm trying. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. I got two lives left
I'm gonna concentrate like I've never concentrated before. Oh
Shit, ah, well Teddy sprinkles. Ah, well, there goes me then
Oh shit, I
Gotta do it again. Alright, I'll be this is different. Hey
Hi
Okay
Did that?
Whoa, uh, uh-huh
Okay, sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry that's my bad I this is new
All I can do in response is cry if I just vomit at random oh this idiot
Oh, this is isn't this isn't this the scary maze
Isn't it isn't this it if I remember correctly? Ye
Come on
Okay, he was expecting a jump scare but no, oh my god is getting weirder every single time
Damn it
Damn it. God damn it
Okay got that. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Easy peasy. Easy squeeze me. Oh shit
Shit I got to do this
Damn it. I'm going oh I made it. Oh my god. I mean it I can't believe I made it. Okay
There we go. There we go. Here we go. Come on, scooch get longer
Get longer stronger. What the hell?
What?
Oh
Shit. Oh my god. This one hurts my eyes so badly
I feel I can feel my brain melting out of my ears. I am going to die. Oh
You gotta I see you gotta stay on this button
Hope hope hope hope there we go
Okay, I probably got no points from that which means I got no lives, but whatever
All right. I just need to get enough Livesay when I go back. It's good. Okay, I don't know I
Don't know I don't like the way these things are looking at me, I don't know
Okay
Alrighty then. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh
Boy, why you know when I first went through this the levels weren't this hard?
BAM oh my god. It takes so much focus. This is like the most focused I ever have to be in my life
Oh my god
Okay, here we go. Oh, hey. How's it going in there?
I don't know what that oh, boy die hurt Oh God
I can't see anything kind of makes it difficult. Oh, I think I saw that was gonna be
Yeah, it's gonna it's gonna gloss right over me
Hurry hurry, hurry hurry. Oh
All right, here we go again, here we go here we go here we go let's do this sacrifice of blood
Okay, if I could just not lose 10 lives right off the bat. I think I'll be perfectly happy
All right, you scrappy bitch? All right. Come back to me. Come ere. Give me the power. Oh
There he goes. He's doing his thing. Oh
Shit oh shit. Oh shit. Ah
lucky lucky me Oh
Give me that pow. Give me it. Whoa there. Oh, that was a god stop
Give me a goddamn second
Okay, here we go. I'm really gonna wham him I'm ready digging scratch
Oh
Yeah more than half more than half on that one with half on that one baby I got nine lives left
I'm a cat that's how many lives we have that is pretty typical and everything that I was talking about
All right, I'm gonna get these you're gonna see just how fricked you are
Excuse my language. Oh
Wow, okay. Okay. Can I just
Get my bearings. Are you fucking with me?
How in the fuck is that fair? Oh
My god
Are you fricking with me one life left? Aah. Aah. Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me? How is that fair?
How is that fair that's fucked up that is fucked up. That's fucked up. All right, fuck that and fuck you. Oh
Well, this is super sexual I'm not sure I'm I'm not sure I'm liking this you just oh
Just really not feeling it, you know
Yeah, but at least I'm there and I got a lot of lives
I got a lot of lives and I got a new best score. This is gonna be great
This is gonna he's gonna turn out great this time. I got 20 lives 20
No way. I could lose all those lives
There's no way all right
Your ass is grass. This time douche hole you're ready for a face full of Puss cuz I'm coming for you
Well, I'm uh, oh you almost got me that time with the same old grabby mechanics. I'm gonna get you all Mogi you ow
Shit, ah shit
That is the least fair thing ever, okay, here we go. I'm ready. Oh
Yeah, oh how do you like them apples, huh? How do you like them apples huh?
Yeah, not so good not so tasty apples, huh? Not so good apples apples were a little rotten
I got 17 lives and a whole lot of fuck and you got a whole lot too bit. Just wait you wait buddy bow
Oh, just you wait. Oh, you think I think that you think that you just you gonna be free, huh?
You think that you did there weren't gonna be repercussions
For what you did to me, huh? Oh shit. Okay Oh
Cock my one more one more. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where's my pal? There isn't my pal
There's my pal. Here we go. All right, I'm gonna really give it to you. Ooh
Ooh
You're gonna get it. Oh, oh you got some more eyes for me to scratch bitch get scratched
Oh, my hand is Grand Baie. Oh
Yeah, it's right. Yeah, it's right. Yes. Oh, yeah. I'll fuck you. I'll fuck you
give fucked
Yes, this pussy ain't so easy
Is it?
Yes, right. Yeah, it's right. Yeah, it's right give me this
Right. Give me those. Give me those. Oh shit. Oh
That cat has a moustache a
Hello. Oh, it is a long time since the heroes were last here
The euros you say I love that moustache
Have you no
You know, no kidding I've noticed that right right, okay. All right. Gotcha
Yeah, uh all the keys and free the prisoners they will help you get to the beasts lair and attack it there
Uh
Yeah, what was your name you didn't even tell me your name sir a mr. Mustache
I I just was going for a walk. I took a wrong turn somewhere. I just want to go home
Dive happened some difficulty now understanding
Why did you lose them just wouldn't a janitor have the copies? Okay. All right, whoa
Whoa, I like a four four sounds good
entering counter world
Eight four
Four why is it full of teeth?
Why is four full of teeth? Wow that got munched? Whoa. Hey, why is it full of teeth?
This isn't that something's not right about this shit just gonna point it out
Some ain't so right
Where is it full of teeth? Why was a unicorn? Oh, no
Shit yeah been slapped in the face. Oh
My god this isn't this isn't that complicated but his goblin gated I got no idea
Who's talking to me? Why are you why are you talking to me?
Good okay, okay
Made it. Oh my god, this this is the
Only hell there's only hell hell this is just Oh, amen. Amen. Are you shooting Sarabhai hut up
you're next I
Wanna go home
I wanna go home
Oh my god
Alright wrap around the wrap around the end and any whinny. I whinny. Yes, I do
We're only halfway through this wonderful counter war
I don't like I don't like I don't like I don't like I don't like I don't like you don't do that
You don't do that to me. Oh shit. Oh, oh, okay. We're fine. Okay, this makes sense
Uh-huh
okay, I
See this makes just so much sense
Okay, here we go
boop boop
Tit. No, you're not gonna get me. No, you're gonna get me. Oh, you're not gonna get me this time. They'll watch this maneuver
Shit shit shit
Shit, I wanna get watched dis maneuver
What the fuck oh, oh shit, oh, it's it's better just
Get
Looked at oh, oh
Oh, what a thumping beat. Oh
That's a heartbeat. Never mind. Not a thumping beat
I wasn't thinkin there was gonna be
Got it nailed it. I'm good. I'm great. Give me those lives. Okay. Let's see what else we got in store
Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit
Ah, we're fine
It's totally fine
Easy Oh like it was nothing. I'm getting good at this. I'm getting so good
There's no way that I can ever not be good. And it's like everyone every corners. Oh, it's new madness around every corner
It's new madness. Oh boy Oh cock. Oh
God damn it. Oh, I wasn't dead there
there
Shit god damn it. Oh
No
No, no, oh
Fuck oh fuck me. Oh god. Holy shit. This is hard
How how what what the fuck what the
500 no, none of that. None of that. None of that the fuck with the fuck
Hoga oh, oh that I don't like any of that
That's some bullshit right there. I'm getting you I
Understand you now. Oh
I can't see don't do that. I can't see don't let oh I can't see hang on
Hang on
Hang on hang on. Oh, there we go
Okay, well we did that I don't know I got 10 lives 11 12 13 14
Okay, what's that oh I see oh
Shit oh fuck me fuck doc ock there's a lot of corpses
I just noticed there's a lot of corpses in that hallway
There's a lot of corpses not my corpse is not not mine the other corpses that aren't mine
Not sure where they came from but uh, not fuck
Made it. Oh shit. No. No the save god cock
Guy hit the save. Oh, hey
Trouble getting ahead derp. No, I'm fine. Fuck. Well. Good luck to you. Oh, I guess I should have I
Guess I could have asked for help
Oh my god
Ah
I made it
I've only got like eight how many left ten I've had ten lives. Okay. Let's see what that
Would see what's up. Let's just see what's up. Okay, don't look so bad
It don't look so bad
It don't look so bad. Don't look so bad. It's not so bad. It's not not so bad. Oh
Ye, okay button. Oh, oh, oh, it's bad. Oh, hey, no, no, no, no no. Oh
Oh
Oh, oh what do I do? Oh
Here comes the money free money. Okay. I got some pals. I think oh
Okay, I
Get it. I think I get it. I don't know what the limits of my flexibility are here. But I think I get it. Oh
Ow
Shit oh
Oh
It's a surreal nightmare. Can I please just get a winning? I know for I don't know how slots really work
So it's just like fruit, I guess can I get some you know pal?
Okay, there's a POW give me that power. I want that. No, I it was supposed to be a pal
Yeah, wild. Oh, oh, oh
Get zapped bitch
Get zapped. Oh shit
How's this? I?
Think house. Yes. Yes pals. Give me the POW. Oh shit. Oh shit. Come on. Come on. Give me no you fuck
There we go. There we go. There we go, Zappa. Barbra Zappa Baba Zappa Baba's appabob. Azapa, baba. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh shit
No, breaking the slot machine. Uh-uh. I
Don't know wasn't me? I didn't do it four lives left. I can do this. I can do this
What the fuck what the fuck how did how the fuck ja how the fuck am I missing
There we go wild zaps
zappity zu
zappity Zeebo
Sam put us up. Okay. I need one more card. Damn it. Okay
There we go. Oh
Baby, oh baby. Oh baby. Oh, baby. No biri. Biri biri Oberer
Whoa. Okay, super red hot jackpot. I'll take it. I don't know what that means
Whoo big win?
Okay, sure. Oh shit. Oh, well, oh, oh god. Oh god. Oh god
No, okay
I'll keep my eyes. Oh fuck
Shit. Aah, oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god one life left. Oh my god. I
thought I was
So close no
I
Was right there god, dammit. Oh, fuck me. Oh
God oh
I'm so heartbroken. I'm so heartbroken. I'm so broken
Okay, here we go. Nine lives all that. I really need you know, all that I ever really needed here comes some money
Okay. Sure. Yeah. Okay. Here we go, six lives plenty of PAL plenty of room to pass ain't gonna see nothing coming their way
They know they know they're done. They dunzo you're done. You're done zou okay we go
Get rekt get shrek rekt
Get rekt come on. Whoa
There we go. God damn hug time. Oh shit doves. That's weird. Oh
Okay, oh
Jesus Halla. Hey, what's up? How's it going?
It's not gonna be geez this is gonna be cat Jesus or something
No
Jesus buddy. Hey do it God's
Okay, all right Linda that's a thing that happened Wow
Yeah, okay. All right. Wow, that's um, yeah, that's Wow
Okay, Wow Wow Wow a lot of lives there good for me. I can't wait to waste them
All right. Only five more to go. Let's blast through these bad boys. Oh
Shit well. Oh
There goes my protection that I just add. Oh, wait. Is that like a special buffer? I get it. Oh, I
Get that at the beginning of the world. Oh, that's the bad. Okay. I didn't know that was the bad I get it
So that's like a shield
That probably gives me one free death. Are ye? Oh
Shit god, damn it. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Yep. Oh, come on. I was so there
There we go easy-peasy should have been easy peasy, I've got this okay, I'm gonna blast through
Oh
Boy a game of snake, huh
Ie ah, come on
Fucking fuck. Oh
That's the slam shut okay, that's stupid
Come on please this real fucking game. Uh, yeah. Yeah
No, you tricked me ah, fuck you oh
Wait, oh
god, damn
oh you
Yam. Oh you oh you yam. Oh
you oh you
You did trick me. You did trick me you did that intentionally. Ah, fuck you
I'm gonna get through one of these with my shield intact
Alright so that goes there a lot of curve ease I don't like the curve ease, but I can do it
Easy with shield intact with shield intact does that give me like a bonus life or something?
Or maybe he's just us save okay again corpses. Why well, fuck me
Shoot. Oh
That's weird owl
Shit okay. Oh
Fuck me. Okay got that
Weirdly oh, oh I see. Oh no. Oh no
Okay, well that was easy, okay, I thought it was gonna be much much much more difficult, but okay I'll take it
Okay, this is bizarre. Oh
Never mind
Okay, well I'll just squander that that's how I roll I just squander all my opportunities, I think I see oh
There is there's a small window of opportunity when these guys go by
Yeah, got it, okay, that was I don't know if that was worth waiting but I got it oh
Come on cock. Oh god, damn it. Ah, fuck me in the butt
No, fuck me. Oh fuck. Oh
God okay. Well, here we go
Yep, there I am. Okay. Well, I didn't even make it to the boss that time. Oh shit
Well, fuck there I go I am lay dead
Mmm, that's bizarre
I don't like that. That's not good. Well, I don't know what that's all about. But okay
Oh, I see. Oh, I see. Oh
Well, fuck god. Damn it Oh
What the fuck? Is this shit? I?
Was through that god damn it god fucking damn it
Come on I was through it
Close
Okay, your Commodore BOSU. I don't know what the boss it do you?
Okay a key right. There is so easy. It's like I could just go grab it which I will
I'm gonna go grab it. I like these space invaders. They're nice. Oh
Oh the mothership Oh, oh
No my key you bastard
Why can't I get through here? There we go. I'm gonna get you. Oh, just you wait. Oh, I'm coming to get you
Oh you were gonna be gone
Hey, wait was I not supposed to get oh shit. I don't know what I just got but I got it. Come on. Oh
Oh
Okay. All right. Oh
It's it's real it's real this so that's why it was space invader, okay?
No, pause this time no scat cat cats cat scratches
Whoa, that's what that do. Oh sure
Oh, why am I hitting? Oh, do you have ovaries? Are you big flying vagina?
I just realized that I don't often have time to look at you when I'm fighting these battles. So, uh
Yeah, you're a big floaty vagina ain't ya?
That's that's fun. That's oh shit. Yeah. I'm hitting you in your quad ovaries. Okay. Yeah, that's your a big vagina
Alright mothership I know that can't be the end of it so come on. Yeah. Yeah, I knew whoa. Whoa, wait whoa, whoa
Oh, I see how you be? Okay. I see trying to chase me huh? Not gonna happen
Where am I with a what the fuck where am I? Oh Sh, where am I?
What the where was I okay? I guess I won I couldn't move
All right, well fine then you just ate up some of my lives but at least I got the key
seize the moment little cats
All right, I will oh, don't worry. Don't worry. I will
Okay, thank you moving on. I don't know what the unicorn gives me. If it does give me anything which I would assume it does
Seems like that would be the oh my god. Hello seems like that would be the logical thing, right?
Each of these things gives me a special power. That's gonna help me through the rest of the game
You know, man, these levels are super weird
I was in the underworld the overworld the outer world a lot of war. Oh shit
Well now is dumb. Hey, but at least it kept the progress of the level. That's that's awfully kind of it
Come on I know fuck off
These guys are trying my patience. Oh my god, I know
What the fuck? Oh boy
Damn it. Oh, I thought I could make it. Okay, I get it
Wait, no, I don't get it. Hang on. Wait a second
Just that easy, huh? It was an illusion to do the other stuff. It was a stupid runaround
It was a fool's errand then I was the fool. Oh boy. Ow
Why?
Shit
I was there fuck you
Whatever whatever, you know, what whatever I don't get in whatever it's fine. Whatever
Whatever this duh. Oh this level. I've already done this level. I know I know this one. Well I died
Anyway, Wow wouldn't you know that mmm that's fascinating?
It seems pretty tame so far except for me being an idiot, of course, but what else is new there? Ah,
I see I see. I see the rush. Oh
Come on I
Was right there I was right there made no sense that I got killed there but then again with me anything is possible
Okay, eggs
Wha eggs? Oh boy eggs. Okay eggs eggs, huh? Okay eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs exit
I don't know why eggs, but you know what? I'm not questioning it. It's just eggs and
Eggs or what it is. How am I supposed to get past these eggs?
Just like that, huh just like that. Okay, let's go the long way around thought of egg go to end my eggs
Hey, okay egg done all right now on to boss I got 12 lives. That should be more than enough to beat a boss
I can do all the rest in a row because I'm so goddamn good at this
Site read these levels. I got by attaboy
Mother fucking shit
Oh
We're flying. Oh, we're in some kind of a hell but uh, oh
ah
I don't like that. Nope don't like that at all. Don't like. Nope. Don't like that. No, I do not like that
Yeah to mannequin esque. It's not good. Nope. Don't zoom in now. Don't zoom in do not zoom in on that
Hell oh
Okay
I'm markiplier. Yeah
I don't know man. I want to go home point at the key point in Icarus helmet Icarus
Okay, oh I'm sure I will there I go paying for it oh
Wow, that's not cool, okay
Ah god, oh god. Oh my god, that is awful
What am I supposed to do? How why good God?
Frickin oh my god. Are you kidding me? What the hell? Okay. I what am I supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do? You are not giving me any clear fucking directions
There's no direction. Oh my god that one life left 12 lives down to one just like that apparently
Fucking
I'm so mad. I'm so mad. This is do a different one. Fuck you the underworld I swear we've been in the underworld
Why the fuck are you kidding me? What the fuck I was right there god damn it
There's sometimes this weird thing we're crossing over between platforms just doesn't work. Sometimes that's so stupid
Motherfucker
Goddamnit, oh
My god, oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Fuck in. Fuck. Oh
My god, are you fucking kidding me?
Come on I've died doing that every time at the beginning of this goddamn level. Why am I not it?
Oh my fucking god. Oh, oh my fucking god
If why
Why am I I'm getting it there every fucking time
Every it's so easy there but here no here impossible for some fucking reason
Why what the fuck why why that should not be it should not be
Every fucking of lost seven fucking lives
Seven fucking lives on that one fucking level, don't you fuckin?
This is so stupid, it's so fucking stupid god fucking damn this game. That's so
ridiculously stupid
This suit makes no sense. That made no sense
What the fuck?
Here we go fast as the light, okay
Made it Oh made it made it made it made it made it two more lives. That's not enough
That's I just want to be very clear not enough. That's not enough live shrimp. Okay
Why shrimp?
Why why shrimp where am I supposed to go? Am I just supposed to make my way through somehow? No boy
There we go. Okay. Shrimp. Yeah. Okay. Yeah shrimp. Alright
this is
Really silly? I don't understand you, but okay
Oh shit, oh, sorry shrimp the shrimp's grade here. Ah
No, I made it wow are those shrimps on poles pole dancing shrimp. Hello. Hi, how are you?
Well, that's too bad
Point at the key. It's a key
Yeah, okay
How about wait I got I got a bunch of those
Okay, sorry, I don't not in my face whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa, whoa, okay, okay
Shit ah, well fuck me then. Oh boy
Why not net why now Jesus Christ a gnat really a gnat is going to try to
Get in my face right now. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god
Oh my god. Oh my god. I've got it. Ah shit. Ah, fuck. Where am I? Where am I here? Ah,
Shit god damn it. Oh
God, oh, fuck. What the fuck? Oh
My god, please just let me finish this
Fuck
It's about to explode get on my back oh, oh
No, oh
No. Oh no. Oh no. No. Oh God, I wasn't able to even touch it
God it wasn't able to control it. That's so fucking stupid
God fuckin
Entering the inner world No, what the fuck?
What the fuck what the fuck what the fuck what the fuck oh my god. Oh
Well shit my god fuck it fuck it fuck that fuck that fuck that
No, I don't want to restart the fucking game. Just get me out of this goddamn world. Fuck this job
I don't care. It says let me restart. I'm not gonna go into that seven lives down on the second fucking level
No, I don't want to go why not why I can go back I don't want to fuck off. Oh
God now I have to die again over and over over and fucking over fucking over and over again fucking over and over again
fuck fuck fuck fuck
Fuck. Fuck. Oh my god, okay
No fuck off
God, damn it. Oh my god, you get higher points and therefore more lives if you're flawless multiple times in a row, and of course
It just had if I didn't want this
Motherfucker, oh boy
Of course
What the fuck oh my god
Three god damn it
I'm suing so good and I go into this with four fucking lives. Oh
Never mind, three. Let's make it now four vote. Yes. What the fuck?
There's no point in this there's no fucking point
I'm getting so mad. I'm so fucking mad. Here we go. Now I have lives. I have 18 lives
This one's hard as shit, but I still should be able to get through it. Hmm
No, motherfucker
What the fuck what the fuck I wasn't even
Motherfucker or whatever, you know, what whatever I'm done trying to ask how
My goddamn sense. Ah
Come on come
On Jesus stop going exactly where I can go
There she is
12 lives at least six lives already Jesus. Okay. Here we go. Here we go
It's about to explode get on my back
Yeah, whatever
No
No, let me control it. Fuck you. God. Fuck. Oh
Fuck it won't let me control it. What the fuck is the point?
Yeah, I made it I know I made it
That's great that I made it
But it wouldn't let me I could not fucking move it I click I move I click I fucking move
That's fine see I can't move my mouse now it does that it does that it locks my fucking mouse
God
Okay, good, great, we got another one fucking wonderful
Motherfucker
No, I did it again God five buck
Hahahahaha
Alright, here we go on to this boss with plenty of lives
Eighteen, that's a good number of lives. Oh, yeah. This guy fuck. He squashed my life super hard, though
I had tons of life's going into him and I still couldn't get him. Here we go again. Here we go again
Here we go again. Oh, yes. Oh, yes. Oh, yes
Yes, yes
Good god, oh my god. Oh fuck just - oh my god. Fuck
God damn it. Uh, fuck me. Oh my god. What the fuck? What the fuck?
Good fucking god
If I can't fucking see anything, how am I supposed to be able to dodge anything?
You fucking piece of shit. Oh you oh, you fucking oh my god
Not this shit No
Goddamnit
Okay, what did I do? Oh fuck this
Fuck this shit. I
Don't know what you want from me. Oh
You fuck
Fucking come on. Oh, and I'm that's done God
Wow God
Oh, just let go
So hard fuck this shit
That's such a fucking stupid boss if I can't fucking see
How can I win?
I'm just gonna go to the fucking basic level get some goddamn lives
Because Jesus Christ, like honestly what the fuck is so fucking stupid
So fucking stupid this stupidest goddamn thing I've ever seen in my life
God dammit. Are you far? Are you fucking serious? Really? I gotta go through a third fucking phase. Oh
My god, oh my god. Oh my fucking god. Oh
I can't see
What a waste of fucking time my god, oh my god. Oh my god, I'm so mad
I'm so unbelievably mad. All right, here's another boss. I
Don't know what this one is. Oh shit. Oh
god
Fuck this shit
Or that or fucking that
14 lives to go into a boss have never oh my god
Hi. Hello
How are you doing?
My name is markiplier
Yes, oh
Don't tell me that shit
I
Don't want to know it okay. I didn't want to know what that was. No, this one's mine. This one's my oh wow
Why okay, I don't need any of this. Oh I get it I get it. Okay well
Holy shit tonight, where am I? Oh my god
And she's broken
You fucking kidding me are you kidding are you fuck are you fucking kidding me?
It bugged out fucking bugged out I'm done I'm walking away from this I'm done. I cannot do this I can't do this
I just can't do this. I can't I can't fucking do it. You're halfway through fuck you. I'm halfway through
Fuck you, I'm done. This is bullshit. This is bullshit. This is a hundred percent bullshit half of the time
I'm trying to control my goddamn character. It doesn't work. Yeah. Well, that's it. I'm done with this
This has been puss
I've been playing this for about two and a half hours and that is just about enough for me the games good
That's the thing. That's surreal and I love it
And like I love the aesthetics of it
But it's just got these if you're gonna have a bullet hell that is this nuanced and this like tight controls and mechanics
You cannot you absolutely cannot lose control the character ever
I can the whole fact that I have to click and hold him down and when I die I have to reek lick or
Sometimes I don't have to reek lick and it's just this I didn't want to go fucking there, but I'm done. Fuck you
Just there's no main menu thing. There's no nope. Just this
Had a bunch of different avatars didn't even know about that
But that would have been cool to know but no, it's fine. This game is good
But man, does it have some flaws? It really really has some serious flaws
There's no way that you can have something this tight. That doesn't work half the time you can't do it
You cannot blind me after I get hit and then I don't know where I am
And then I just get hit again like it'd be fine if I was still moving
after I got hit and it was one of those things where I got hit and it was like
Oh
Like maybe even no invulnerability like half a second and it's just like keep going but the fact that my character stops
Is just so unbelievably unfair and then that last boss is being broken. That's that is what it is
So I suffered through this hard. I suffered through it very hard
I did great for I'm I'm I'm saying I did great and I did do great I did great but I'm done
So thank you everybody so much for watching
If you want to play puss for yourself and put you through some horrible horrible stuff
Click the link in the description below and you will have a good time. But other than that it is a cool game
I love the aesthetics of it, but it's just like
Too much too much too much too much too much too much too much to be fun
anyway, thank you everybody so much for being a
PI
Welcome back to Poulos. Um, this is actually the same part. I am just coming back to it from another day
So today I was looking at the news of this game and apparently
They've put out a patch that addressed some of the bugs that I was encountering
So I wanted to give this game another try another honest try to see if it was
Something that I could actually wrap my head around now, so I'm gonna give it again. I've taken some time away
I'm not as pissed off as I was and I'm just gonna try to enjoy it, but I did change
My avatar to something that was a bit more representative of my mood. Well, my angry kitten seems to be working
I'm not sure like it's it's gonna be very difficult for me to discern like whether or not something is fixed or not
I mean honestly, how would I be able to tell but if it is then I just will be able to beat it
I guess so. Give me a second to get back to where I was. I still don't expect it to be easy
But if it's manageable, which the other one didn't seem to be then I'll be much happier
At least I haven't regrets completely for my skill set. I mean also my wrist isn't hurting me which it was before
Yi-yi-yi. Yeah, yeah. Yeah
easy-peasy
Easy-peasy. Okay. I'll be back when I get to the boss you guys worries
At least I remember these levels that's that's pretty much all I can really say about it right now
Things do lose their charm once you've died to them ten bajillion times. Oh,
God damn it Oh Oh God, why is
What now my mouse doesn't stay in the game
Why
What why would it not? Why would my mouse nest? Oh, oh. Oh God. They've made it worse
they've
Somehow made it worse
Because just imagine I'm in a boss fight and my mouse goes out of the screen after I'm dying and I'm trying to get back
In and but my mouse is off-screen and then I click outside the window and then I die again
See right there right there. I just clicked outside the goddamn window when I Oh,
How'd they make it worse? How did they make it worse? All right, let's see how this goes, I guess
Here comes the boss
It's not gonna go. Well. Yeah, if here he comes. Alright and let's see if this is gonna be any better
Probably not all things considered. All right, here we go. Oh
Shit. Oh, they really got me that time
Okay, that's a little better because now I don't have to click
Miss me
That's me. Okay now I'm in this phase
Ah
Shit didn't get them all I tried but I'm doing a lot better
He's a far cry better than whoa. What the fuck? Okay. Thank you for more immunity by the by
That is definitely more immunity than it was
It was marginally less stupid than it was. There we go
Okay, this is actually better. It was not better before but this is actually better shockingly. It is somehow better. Oh
Shit god damn it. Oh, I almost had that. Okay
Well now I got these assholes to deal with it really is beneficial to get that in one phase. Oh
Shit god damn it. Yeah, the longer immunity is just an absolute must I think that was the biggest pain in the dick
Okay, this is actually
This might be manageable ass shit. You're not gonna give me another fist face
Okay
There we go it tries again, okay, just gotta get you and that was it okay
Get this shit Oh get your shit slapped that
Felt good it felt good. Look at your fucked up fit. I can't move. Okay. Well, okay. There we go
I guess now I got it. Well wasted a life. But yeah
You stupid shit you stupid piece of garbage you value you thought you could get the best of me
Yeah. Yeah. Look at your stupid face. That's okay. Oh
Can I oh
It did the thing that I said it was gonna do fuckin Christ. Can you use give me another fist pounding, please?
I I hate that I have to ask for that outright, but if you could just give me another fist pounding, that'd be great
Just pound me. There we go. Give me in there. All right, I'm gonna try to get these all in one go this time
Okay, who's got this? I got this that's right me. I've got this
Okay, that doesn't help nobody. There we go. That helps me. Okay. Someone pick me up someone pick come on. Come on, baby
Come on, baby. There we go. A little more speed would be great
Where you gonna go? Where you gonna go? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's good. No, that's not good
This good does want to eat it's gonna go oh shit
Come on, come on. Come on. Oh, I've got two more. Come on. I can make this. Oh, fuck me. Come on. Oh,
Please there we go. Ah, whoa, so close goddamnit. If I don't get this in this next go I'm gonna be sold my head
Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Okay, that's fine
Made that just give me a goddamn pounding
Okay, pound me. No not like that. God dammit. Ah
Fuck just Oh God, really you missed
Fuck come on, doh. Come on No, Oh, oh my god. Just fucking pounded reve reve
Alright last one. I'm gonna get you so good. You're gonna get got okay. I just need to wait for the slow Crawley boy
This guy right here. He's gonna slow crawl right where I need to be and then I've got this guy in the fucking bag Oh,
Get ready to be well get your shit slapping
Oh fucking shit slap you slap get slapped
That's right
Well, maybe if you didn't suck so much ass now, I'm not human I guess that's one answer. Oh
It got us thank you for the key, huh
Oh, yeah, sure, okay. Thank you
Don't call me that Joe. Call me. Call me that louder
All right. Well
well, damn, I uh, I
Did it?
Shockingly I did it it was marginally better. Oh, oh, oh god. Oh god. I was not ready for this
Okay, I didn't know I get this at at the end of every level
So that noooo!
We'll never mind that I guess I'm not gonna have any benefit out of that that's wonderful, okay
Well, do I keep going now or what? I (Mark stutters) think i am gonna die again
All right
Let's try it if I die even once I'm done
But if I if I get this and I'm able to beat this boss too, then I'm gonna keep going
Alright back an' a' fourth(e?) oh well, I'm a dumbass
What fuck what the fuck I don't know what icarus does I'm not 100% sure, but
Hopefully Icarus isn't just a complete useless waste of my life cuz servant for the entirety of my life is a long time
Hopefully maybe it's not a long time at honestly, who knows? Okay, this is going smoothly. This is going way too smoothly
Honestly, I'm just bracing for when it goes horribly wrong, which it will
halfway through already this is
It's going real good
I swear that it didn't used to be like this where I can just click on it and then let go
Because if it was like that before and I just wasn't doing that then I hate myself
it's the only answer I have to that if it if it was if it was like this before because I
Swear, I've tried to do this and it just was not working
dah doot dah - oh, thank you time wizard
Okay, well I'm all off
Well, fuck man, oh
Okay. Oh, well, I'm out! PFFFFF I knew it was gonna go bad at some point. Then there went bad. All right boss, time
boss time! good number of lives not as much as I would want but good number of lives. I don't
remember this boss at all. Oh
Ah, this is the one where I got stuck on not terribly the worst but just like I got stuck. Oh
well, there's me clicking out again. hey buddy!
Hey! you looking good! no this one is
mine
Loop all right, where am I? Can I okay. There we go. Oh
Shit Oh fuckin Christ. Okay. Great. Please do not do that repetitiously
Just please that's all I ask. Oh
Oh, oh, okay. Well, that's something
So the trick of this guy is just like he's hitting himself
So quit hitting yourself, you stupid fool. Okay, if I could stop dying too easy shit. Oh my god. Oh my god
Oh my god, I cannot see oh
I can't see shit
Whoa, it's just a wall. I can't okay, I guess that was it then
He he got stuck. But this time he just killed him Oh Oh
Baby I'm angry, but you know hi there
Hi. Oh, I'm an angry Kid this is going shockingly. Well all the sudden
Mm-hmm. I guess now I get chance for lives. So that's that's nice. Oh
Crap well, I'm not gonna get any lives cuz I'm not able to actually hit any. Oh god. Why am I not hitting anything?
Ah, well shit got one more. That's all that really matters. Okay lock them unlock them lock the lock. Um
lick'em welcome
Give them
Turducken. Okay. There we go. And in okay, is this the last?
levels entering
okay, this looks
Awful. Okay think I go this way. I'm not a hundred percent sure. But okay, I think what the fuck really?
Oh well
Joke's on me for going for that
But that was interesting that must be the new Kitty's doing
Whoa, oh did not see those coming. Okay, this is gonna be a bitch to go down here. Okay safe here
And then okay, I think
Miss Kitka Piske get a new high score and that's real good. Oh, I mean oh,
Well, this looks unfriendly, I mean it's not too too hard
But just collectively it's a little stressful a little stressful but again doing relative
What am I looking at I don't X I'm not gonna look at it too closely because I if I do I'll die
So I'm not gonna look at it
Okay, I'm having trouble understanding this
Yeah, let's slow this down, please thank you. Oh, thank you. That was lovely
just what the doctor ordered
Thank goodness for that. That bad was good. That was very helpful. Very helpful
What's the deep top? I?
Think that's a bug
Yep, I'm almost positive. That's a bug. That's the timer thing and it's super bugged. Yeah, that's not supposed to happen. I'm I'm
Percent certain now. It's just this ticking time bomb. That's just making me stressed. I better no, nope still there
Okay, and I die there. Oh, no, please do not tell me it's gonna be a boss run
Is it really gonna be a boss run?
Are you really honestly gonna make me go through every boss again in a row
You better not please tell me you're not doing that Oh
What is that? I don't I don't know what that is. What is Oh God Oh
No, okay well, oh boy, okay
Well, this isn't the worst thing in the world
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Oh well taught me once fool me once
Fool me toos. Fool me Deus. I don't know Who am I have I missed one. Oh, I see
Okay, I get it
Of course
Everything's shaking which is so good for being able to see where I'm going. Alright, here we go
I have no idea what this boss is like I have no idea but it's probably gonna be really freaking difficult
Okay, here we go here
We go. Here we go. Here we go. Okay. Hello. Hi go. Oh
Okay
You got it, but where's your God now meow? I don't know look I'm yelling up a storm
Alright, let's just do it. One of these was was it supposed to be what am I doing?
What am I doing? Am I supposed to bomb something?
Okay, I don't know what I'm doing but okay whatever oh boy hello friend Oh
What are you doing? Oh, that's easy enough, I guess. Oh
Shit didn't even see those. Oh my god. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay, okay
Okay, okay. Ahh. God dammit. I was going for the stupid time slower
I mean, they must be giving me tons of time slow for a reason cuz otherwise, you know
What else would I do with my life? Whoa, hey, buddy
Please get those out of here. Okay so far, so not bad. There's something off to the left with a health bar
He's supposed to do probably throw a bomb at it or something. You might guess anyway
Ah, there we go. Oh
Man these are hard to see Hey look away. It's the unicorn over there. What's the unicorn doing? Oh,
It's helping me with the time. That's right. It's the time the unicorn gives the time. I mean, that's very helpful
Very helpful. I just feel like they're gonna take it away from me when I needed the most which is gonna really suck
No, not there. What the fuck? Okay. Yeah. All right. Give me a bomb. Give me a bam
There's the Bam's here's the delecious Bam's get that over there. Whoa shit
Come on, man. Dad Oh kitty cat with the hearts. That's what you give me right if I remember correctly
Not that this is gonna do anything just yet, but I wanted to push it over there because I'm OCD like that
I just wanted it to be nice and oh shit. Oh shit. Oh
shit
Okay, Bam's I like grams kitty. Can you give me a heart?
Give me a sweet life. That'd be nice again. That doesn't really help me. Oh, I guess it's not supposed to help me
Considering that they're bombs, probably
You know like like Bowser throwing his ticky tacky things
It doesn't really want you to use them against him
But you know, that's just the eventualities of what happens because he's stupid and this goat guys pretty dumb poo
Okay, here we go. Here we go. Wait when he's a little slow down the time
Getting my clock set a little bit more less stupid. Yeah. Well, I did a priest open. Anyway. Oh, no, he's dead
Okay, I did it just right
Jesus Jesus is here
Boy, oh shit. Everything's gonna be. Okay. Jesus has arrived. Oh
Shit Oh Oh God, that didn't he'll be a nil. Oh, this is a pattern. Okay. I just can't really uh
Patterns just hard to see okay
Pattern pattern pattern pattern it is a pattern. It's a patterns. It's just two spiraling. Oh, it's two spirals, uh, whatever
Well, Jesus, are you gonna help or not? It's kind of like a Satanist thing here
Maybe you should you know do something about that seems like your territory more than anything. I can't see shit
Okay, you better give me some to Bhama
Do this the saying?
Really you some to buy. I'm also kitty cat. What are you doing? Can you help her what Oh,
Shot goddammit. Well, I'm just bleeding lives now
Like a fool. Oh shit, like a fool I am give me so there we go. Okay. There we go. Give me this
I'm gonna bomb you with all four do shit. Why did that? Not last that didn't last long at all
Come on
Don't suck. It. Don't suck. It. Don't suck I sucked it. Well dolphin man's here. So that's
Good, I guess ten lives left. I got one more kitty cat to blow up kitty cat cultists to blow up
Oh, well that I don't think that was bullshit. Come on. Give me two like the area's darius darius
Darius, darius now we're gonna get aldo bamos all the bing bang bomb boomers. Oh, yeah
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh
We come it's time we must win, okay
Transform you say trance. Yeah
Transform Jesus by the power of Jesus
Alright, okay. Alright, okay. Okay. I see you
Okay
Alright
Alright, I get you. I'm seeing what I'm picking up what you're putting down. I'm picking it up
Form of oh, whoa
I love the spiral out into existence. Yes, beautiful. Now, you're gonna get slapped. I
Don't care if you are goat or the devil. You're gonna get slapped. Oh shit. Oh you're getting so slapped. I
Don't know what I'm supposed to be. Oh
My suppose a dodge in any way shape or form
That's something I should be doing. I guess I guess oh shit. I don't know what oh shit. Oh
Shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. No shit. No shit. No shit
Bullshit. Oh god, no shit. No
Jeez, ohms. Oh
Thank you, I don't know when I got that but I hid these things got damn just hit him. Oh my god
Okay, here we go. Here we go. Here we go
Can I get on can can our powers combine to be a little more useful, you know what I mean?
They're just a little bit lackluster
Get rekt goat man. Oh
You're gonna put up your shield again, aren't you? Yeah, you are don't act like you're not. Whoa wasn't gonna BAM
You're done. So you're done. So ones. Oh
You're done Z one Z Z. Oh, yeah, finishing blow baby. Oh
Baby oh, yeah
Hi
Oh
But I think that's very professional doc
Is this like the the beginning of the animal with Bob not Brendan Fraser, but you know who Oh,
Cerberus Wow
the best creation Wow the mothership
Yep. That was a vagina. Yeah, that was if I didn't even connect the mother ship thing
That was just a big ol floating vagina or uterus. Sorry uterus. None of a Chinese uterus Subaru
Jackpot see mistress. Yeah, I didn't notice your tentacles
Bahamut
Vomit bottom it got wrecked Icarus. Oh
It's nice
baby real nice chronic horn
Cronic horn-like Chronos for time Jay good old JC man to see
Rick to fish. Oh hell. Yeah just a normal fish
Princess. Oh
Look at Prince go
push
And push and a boy we had a boy go get him push. You got him. Yeah. You got him
made by team coil that was really well done and
The patch it despite me clicking out of the screen fixed a lot of my grievances
I didn't run into nearly as many problems. There wasn't the problems of dying repeatedly to a boss
I was actually able to like dodge things properly. It made sense. It worked out
Well, I don't know what they changed with the going outside the screen, but it worked for everything else
So that was much better much tighter much better controls
I like that that was good and you obviously can see that there was a change because I went from dying repeatedly
To one shotting every boss. I didn't lose a single time this whole time
I mean I died of course, but I didn't lose game over
So that was good boost loves me. Oh, I don't puss loves me. Oh, thank you so much close
Alright, and thank you everybody so much for watching. Thank you for putting up with my anger
I know this is a long let's play but hey, I like doing that
sometimes I want to finish a game on one video occasionally makes for a more interesting and well-rounded experience I'd say so
Thank you everybody so much for watching and oh, we don't have to go through this again. We're good
I didn't even get a score for that. So thank you for that
Thank you everybody so much for watching
And if you didn't know already there is a way you can help me
Make cool projects in the future if you look down just below this video
you'll see a big join button by the subscribe button where you can click on and help support cool projects like
Wilfred mother love and Wharf stash in the future you'll also get some perks for doing it. So please look at it
See what you get and see if it's worth it for you
Thank you
Everybody that has and thank you everybody the will and thank you everybody for watching and as always I will see you in next video
Bye. Bye